backups
we love net Netflix quality um
Productions okay well in which case
let's kick off so um we've we've had a
couple of technical problems with the
stream so now we're going to go
pre-recorded instead which is absolutely
fine so um we're going to talk about
quite a few things today now one big
theme I think is talking about
inactivism and the kind of compatibility
uh between the free energy principle and
an activism uh we're going to talk about
um uh now we have to be very careful how
we pronounce this words Auto poetic
is that right Maxwell that's right yes
amazing um give me when I get it wrong
I'm gonna get it wrong I'm sorry so talk
about Auto periodic and activism which
which of course was the brain uh child
of uh Varela and um there's an
interesting paper that came out which
was actually quite critical of of Effie
people we're going to talk about some of
the points in that paper and that was
called laying down a forking path
tensions between an action and the free
energy principle and in that paper there
were a few areas so there was the
definition of auto uh poesis uh
historicity so we'll talk about
um a temporal sequence invariance and
non-steady state equilibria and what it
means to be ergodic
um there's this critique about the
non-stationarity of distributions and
also a really interesting discussion
about internalism versus externalism
because of course the the inactive view
is is a form of externalized
um cognition which is this very
interesting view that you have
cognizising elements outside of the Mind
in the around you so we'll talk about
that as well we'll touch on goal
directedness and also structure learning
which is a really really exciting thing
in in any any Bayesian cognitive
framework now on the call today we have
obviously first of all Professor Carl
friston the inventor of the free energy
principle and active inference a man who
requires no introduction whatsoever
Professor friston welcome to the show
great to be back
fabulous we also have Dr Maxwell
Randstad one of the top scholars in the
free energy principle and the active
inference literature of course we've had
Maxwell on very recently but welcome
back Maxwell
always a pleasure generally amazing and
we also have a new face uh Professor
Buckley would you like to introduce
yourself
yeah yeah so uh yeah my I'm a faculty
member at the University of Sussex but I
also work uh with verses with Maxwell uh
and Carl so I have a background
originally in physics the postgraduate
in physics and then moved into cognitive
robotics I was kind of working in the
behavior-based robotics uh and an
activism somewhat early on my uh my PhD
moved into kind of theoretical
neuroscience and kind of really uh got
interested in the free energy principle
about uh eight or nine or so years ago
and wrote a review on it uh originally
uh you know wanted to challenge it and
then eventually fell in love with it and
now I think it's the right way to go for
it for what we ought to do
so yeah I came as a skeptic and then
have been bashed into into place I do
think now this is uh is the correct way
to think about things amazing well let's
let the bashing commence well we'll move
straight on on the subject of inactivism
so there was this paper laying down a
forking path tensions between an action
and the free energy principle and um the
name is very hard to pronounce it was
esquiel uh D power Lola power
oh yeah
okay thank you so much for that now um
now just just to be fair to them uh
because Maxwell you did actually couch
fep as an activism 2.0 uh despite the
inactivist's rejection of information
methods and um maybe we should start by
defining an activism and and also
there's some similarities with this
other idea called ecological psychology
um so why don't why don't we just start
by Framing some of these ideas up
that sounds good yeah I think that's a
great idea
do you have a like a pre-prepared
definition you wanted to share or do you
want us to Riff on this
well why don't why don't we start with
uh varela's inactivism so there are some
so it's um in terms of philosophy there
are hints of existentialism and
phenomenology and Eastern influences and
focus on lived experience and and stuff
like that one of the and the core things
is that they reject information
processing and computationalism they
focus on actions and interactions
they're
um it's a very embodied tradition so why
don't we just kind of start with that
okay yeah that's a great way to set it
up well I I mean we should we should
probably just add a little bit of uh
context and a few caveats before
launching into this so I think uh Chris
and I uh are of the generation that was
trained in the inactive embodied
tradition uh I would describe myself as
a reformed inactivist uh I don't know if
Chris you uh resonates I still believe
in activism yeah
um so these uh the inactive approach is
one of the so-called four e approaches
uh that have become very popular since
the 90s and I would argue is at least in
in the more philosophically informed
corners of cognitive science and
Neuroscience basically the dominant uh
theoretical Paradigm right now
um so uh it we have to say there's a
this is a broad Church of approaches
that that go from
um a more kind of minimalist recognition
that cognition involves bodily processes
to uh the more radical approaches that
you were describing uh earlier that just
uh wholesale reject uh information
Theory the computation the computational
metaphor for mine the mind is basically
a kind of computing device
and uh yeah the the inactive approach
grew out of Auto poetic Theory
um they're distinct it's important to
say so um Auto poetic theory was
developed by uh maturana and barela
um sometime in the 1980s and uh 90s
um and it was a very mechanistic
approach to uh mind I mean you know the
some of the early kind of Flagship
papers in in this tradition are um what
the Frog's eye tells the Frog's brain
and this kind of stuff so you know
hard-nosed kind of systems biology type
thinking
um and uh I mean there was basically a
break in the literature where
um
due to Varela in a lot of ways uh the
emphasis uh moving from kind of
mechanistic models to phenomenology to a
kind of more Dynamic uh coupling
Interactive kind of mode of explanation
um so yeah the uh inactive approach is
basically committed to this idea
fundamentally that cognition is
basically bringing about a world a
structured world of meaning and
significance uh through adaptive
appropriate actions left in the world so
um the uh the slogan is um you know uh
yeah exactly uh constructing uh this
meaning uh you know laying down a path
and walking I think is the the slogan
the poetic slogan form uh that's so uh
popular
um yeah and and it's more radical
inclinations uh this inactive approach
says um dynamical systems is really the
way to study uh systems that have mind
um and so the kind of the background
assumption there is that there's a fork
in the in the road somewhere you know uh
where we have to choose between
information Theory and Dynamics
um and yeah they obviously go down the
Dynamics path
um so I think that's the setup um and
before launching into criticism I should
say that we we as a community genuinely
appreciate and benefit from friendly
critical engagement uh so I just want to
caveat all this by saying that the Chris
criticism comes from a place of wanting
to build community uh from a place from
our hearts basically uh and uh yeah
although I'm gonna be saying a lot of
critical stuff about the inactive
approach uh in my heart I'm in an
activist I think just that the um a lot
of the uh
a lot of the the methodology and
explanatory constructs uh that are
leveraged in the approach are
problematic and in particular you see
this come out when the free energy
principle comes into play um
so so Chris do you want to add anything
to that that definition yeah I mean I
guess it's like I I see I'm going to use
this kind of phraseology it was in uh in
one of Carl's books which is a low road
and a high road uh an activism I I
basically brought up a low road in
activist right so this is kind of
rejection of representationalism uh in
cognitive architectures it was a move
away from good old-fashioned artificial
intelligence to embedded and embodied
agents so this is kind of the origin in
in Rodney Brooks's behavior-based
approaches to to Robotics and those are
the kinds of ideas uh I still Embrace
and then there's the kind of high road
and activism uh which kind of Embraces
autopriest and operational closure at
its heart and I I mean to me I mean if
you're if you're a higher an activist
they are the same thing they are they
come from the same place but I think
there's a kind of there is a there are
messages to take from an activism on the
low road which is super important for
cognition right without kind of going
into the depths of the or uh autopoiesis
just in terms of like the language I
think
um I I think there is a split between
dynamical systems theory which is kind
of the origins of uh descriptions of
autocratic systems and information
Theory but that that Community has begun
to embrace you know a little bit of
information Theory but intends to uh has
been done through kind of
phenomenological models simple models
rather than kind of have this kind of uh
theoretical angle or a deep theoretical
basis in something like Bayes that like
we're doing right I mean so that paper I
I read it before we come that to me it
doesn't seem you know some of the
language is quite dismissive but to me
it seems an opportunity to see uh
whether we can reconcile these
Frameworks and I think they've done a
nice job in pointing where there are
maybe things we can express better
within the free energy principle that
kind of address things like operational
closure I feel that those Community
sometimes feels like it has to be
divided uh but I I I'm very much a a an
inclusive uh person so you know anything
with some really nice down love between
people in activism and what we do in the
inactive inference and the free energy
principle interesting I mean I'll bring
uh Professor friction in in just a
second but I was reading this very
interesting paper by by Maxwell uh
written in um I think it's 2019
multi-scale integration internalism and
I was 21 okay sorry there's it's the um
the the multi-scale integration paper
and you know of course this this um an
active philosophy is all about
externalism so you know you actually
have these cognizing um elements outside
of of where the brain is and in a way
it's um uh there's this Helm hopsian
sharp separation between the organism
and the environment which is perhaps
embraced by neuroscientists but the
interesting thing about the free energy
principle is is I think it maintains
some vagueness about this notion of
whether it's an internalist system where
you have strong representations and uh
predictive power about what's going on
in the world around you
um versus being this kind of
um dynamical externalist inactive type
system and in that paper Maxwell USA
saying that well actually we can
integrate the two views because you can
have these nested boundaries and as
Professor friston has said
um human Minds The reason we have this
temporal depth of planning and
sophistication and representation
building and so on is because we're at
the top of the stack but there's many
many layers below us where Perhaps it is
more of a an active externalized form of
cognition so we can kind of speak to
both worlds but Professor first and
perhaps you could come in on that
yeah I was frightened you were going to
ask me well you know if I had anything
to add about inactivism because I
haven't uh I'm here to find out whether
I'm an activist or not so at the end if
somebody can tell me whether I'm an
activists there's probably some nuanced
version of it it's like a moderate
epistle logical and activist victim
um so
I think
um
with that last Point Tim um I I think is
a really interesting one and in fact I
just reviewed a paper for synthes
yesterday I think touching upon this
issue from a philosophical perspective
um
put very simply the free energy
principle basically will accommodate
both perspectives it rests upon an
externalist view of the universe as a
random dynamical system that just by
equipping that system with a partition
that separates something from everything
else then induces an internalist
explanation for the way that thing makes
sense of its universe so there is a a
necessary eneshing of both the
externalist and the internalist
perspectives you know put it another way
the internalist perspective is entirely
licensed
um in terms of the interpretation of
self-organization as a process of
inference and you know with that an
explicit commitment to a certain kind of
representationalism but that only
inherits from the you know where you
start from which is an externalist view
of the thing in an external world with
with a with a particular metaphysics
here described in terms of random
dynical systems and it's interesting
also you pick up on this fork in the
road which I confess I completely I do
not understand
um you know all interesting information
Theory read as probability Theory
um that is used uh in physics inherits
from dynamical systems
um you know we're talking thing ranging
things ranging from the master equation
through to Schrodinger's wave equation
the focal Planck equation comma forward
equation all of these are information
theoretic treatments of dynamical
systems so I don't really understand the
nature of this fork and so I Pro I
probably should now pass it back
can I follow up on that Chris and then
and then maybe you can answer it I don't
get it either and so what what confuses
me about it is um one of the the
brilliant things about the free energy
principle to me is this exact connection
between random dynamical systems of a
certain degree of complexity let's say
approaching Auto poetic right and and
this behavior that they must manifest in
order to
to be what they are right which is which
is this balancing between between you
know uncertainty and prediction and that
sort of thing so to me they're they're
hand in glove and so I guess my question
to you Chris since you were going to
jump in there is what is the source of
this conflict like is it a fear that if
it's linked if you link the information
and and Dynamics in a certain way that
they have to conform to this principle
that we're all going to be put out of
work or we're not going to be able to
study the things we want to study just
do you mind if I just quickly interject
with a little bit of context okay
um just to I wanted to elaborate a
little bit on what uh Carl said because
I think there were some things in here
that might in what Carl said that might
not be clear to uh the audience so that
bears repeating
um the first is that uh there's this
idea that Markov blankets kind of
seclude the organism uh from the
environment this is sort of like the
helmholtz style story where our
relationship to the environment is in
some sense only indirect and we are
separate from the environment by our
Marco blanket the important thing to
point out is that just definitionally
the Markov blanket comprises the set of
degrees of freedom that separate and
couple systems together so it's it's
it's not the the veil it's the interface
so that's the first thing to point out
uh so uh a radically internalist
interpretation of the free energy
principle doesn't work because you
actually need external states to be in
play for the math tour if there are no
external States then there's nothing to
track and there's nothing beyond the
markout blanket so you don't get the
story started like it doesn't get off
the ground uh if you don't assume that
there are these things that the particle
in question that the thing that you're
interested in is a tuning to in the the
so there needs to be something to couple
and to be separated from for the story
to get off the ground so uh yeah it's a
it if you write down your dynamical
systems equations it's always the
generative model that we keep talking
about is defined over your internal
blanket and external state so that's the
first point what Carl is saying is the
other the other way around too which is
if you're empty of all internal States
and and you every single state you have
can be influenced from the outside well
there's less to talk about well then
you're not a thing strictly speaking
right uh that so you know the it's it's
definitional to what it is to be a thing
to have this kind of interface between
that thing and other things so that's a
first point
um so the the internal States as you're
as you're pointing out do play an
asymmetric role so the fep says if you
have this boundary then the internal
states are going to parameterize a
belief about external States so you do
get this kind of internalist looking
thing going as well so that there is a I
think a a kind of reconciliation of
internalism and externalism under the
free energy principle this is what the
2019 paper that you uh are referring to
is about it's called multi-scale
integration and that's precisely the
idea the things that look separated at
one scale can be integrated within you
know the auspices of an overarching
structure at the scale above and so on
and so on and so on we're separate as uh
individuals but we're coupled in this
active inference community and you know
arguably there's an intentionality also
at play there uh same thing for
ourselves right our cell cells are
separate because they have their
individual boundaries but then they're
integrated on the time scale of me as an
organism and so on
um so that's that was about internalism
and externalism I wanted to speak
quickly to the split between Dynamics
and information Theory whenever I talk
to my friends in high-end mathematics
about this they are always as perplexed
as you know Keith and Carl you are
because it's a nonsensical starting
point
um to do dynamical systems theory
seriously you at some point are going to
need to appeal to information theoretic
uh measures so for example uh distances
in state space so you know the
inactivists are all fun you know they
like to appeal to dynamical systems
theory and stuff but the systems that
they're considering are usually
extremely simple with a few degrees of
freedom that are coupled together but if
you want to do like you know grown up
dynamical systems theory then you're
going to need to appeal to things like
information length to describe the
really the metrics on your state space
you can't avoid that uh similarly when
we're talking about information we're
talking about dynamical you know the
dynamic time course of the these
coupling so we're interested in the
Dynamics of information these things are
not actually separable the idea that
they are uh comes from a philosophy
actually uh it's a set of papers uh from
the basically late 80s early 90s by Van
gelder uh and port
and at the time you know dynamical
systems theory was a new thing in
cognitive science and what they were
saying was hey there's this approach
that we can take it's dynamical systems
it's not computational and um basically
it moved from there to there's a there's
this alternative approach that's
mutually incompatible and that shift
kind of happened Slowly by a
self-referential literature so you know
this is where I'm going to be a bit
critical uh you can really do the
historiography and Trace these claims
back to uh I mean basically van gelder
and port and to some extent Gibson but
these folks net they don't offer a
formal argument right like they're not
saying here's the proof that dynamical
systems and computational approaches are
like incompatible they're just starting
with this gut feeling that hey maybe
there's something different here and
then that turns into I would argue
scleroder sizes or like hardens into
like a an a priori dogmatism
that isn't necessary yeah exactly uh
that is just based like I was saying on
this kind of circular you know we're
just citing other philosophers who cite
other philosophers who are in making
this stuff up at the at the bottom so uh
yeah I mean I kind of feel like this is
a problem with the philosophy literature
is like you know taking just conceptual
arguments from other philosophers maybe
a bit more seriously than they should
without really taking the time to do the
proper historiography looking where
these claims are originating and then
asking the question is there any real
warrant for this kind of Separation so
yeah I've been going around recently
saying that yeah this uh split between
Dynamics and information theory is
mostly in people's imaginations there's
no mathematical basis for it and Chris
sorry
you want to jump in no no thank you you
wanted to jump in earlier and maybe talk
about your personal Journey might come
into play here yeah I mean Maxwell's um
you know said some really interesting
stuff there I mean I guess I take a a
slightly less hotline on that right I
mean I think it's a historical thing so
Tim Elder were looking at deterministic
dynamical systems theory like this is in
the absence of noise and unless you do
ensembles of systems it's not there's no
clear pathway then to to information uh
Theory and and initially in models uh
when in the 80s and 90s it would
typically yeah determine the state
Dynamic systems theories looking at
bifurcations and so on and then but
obviously the Richer the Richer set of
descriptions is stochastic down ample
systems three and that's when
information Theory becomes Irreplaceable
right let's become and then they've come
fully enmeshed these these descriptions
as Carl writes about um so nicely in
lots of his work right but I think you
know I I didn't see the forking path as
kind of this I know that in the
community that there's a history of
using dynamical systems theory and
there's a sense in which the free energy
has really embraced information Theory I
didn't see that that's uh as a as a key
uh the fork the key in the fork of the
path right
um I mean I I got to say that it's a
it's way out of my area this uh this
kind of depth of philosophy but it
seemed to me that kind of the problems
operate the definition of operational
closure that's it that seemed to be uh
um upsetting to
um you know Randall bearing is equal to
parallel and and the the fact that they
don't think that can be embraced by the
tenets of the free energy principle I
mean I don't I think they they made a
nice case I don't think it a priority
that's the case I I can't see there was
a hands-down argument that there is this
forking path it I still think it's an
interesting angle to take uh to think
deeply about operational closure within
the free energy principle is um Maxwell
has and he's going to tell you the
answers to this but I you know uh so I'm
just aware of the the trickiness and
defining operational closure that's
happened in the literature in the last
20 years and then really in an inability
to kind of really get a concrete
quantitative description what we mean by
operational closure uh and so you know I
guess it's uh to say that we've simply
solved it within the free energy
principle that might uh that might have
put some backs up somewhere but you know
Maxwell's maybe can give you a bit more
insight to this because he's thought
that uh deeply about how to define
uprise enclosure within the fridge can I
can I um can I frame it up for you
Maxwell so um the paper quoted you
actually I think you you um you said on
on one of your papers that there is an
analogy
um almost a direct mapping between this
concept of organizational closure and a
Markov blanket and of course the Markov
blanket is this conditional Independence
that you were talking about and you and
you also called it an interface earlier
on and
um when they speak about the definition
of autoparesis they say that I think the
way that you folks in the fep literature
culture is mostly as a form of autonomy
which is this ability to maintain your
own identity under precarious position
you know um situations and they say um
well the the Varela kind of definition
of autoparesis is very much about
um structure and all organization so
it's not it's not just maintaining your
own identity but but it's about
um this self-organization and this kind
of generating structure as well so I
wonder just just with those things on on
the table could could you
Could you um absolutely so in in that
paper I confessed that I probably should
have spoken we probably should have
spoken a bit more precisely we say the
Markov blanket formalism uh what we mean
by that is and I don't think that this
was fully appreciated by the authors at
the time
um
what we mean is Mark all blankets and
the generative models right because so
what you know the claim is right let's
remind the audience just put the terms
on the table a generative model right is
our model of the dependencies that link
the states and parameters that make up a
given system right so uh it is our way
of talking about basically the causal
connective tissue or structure that
underwrites a given system and what the
free energy principle says is if the
underlying system has is disconnected in
a certain appropriate way
then you get this tracking behavior and
formally speaking it says if there's a
Markov blanket in this dependency
structure right if conditioned on
certain blanket States then it looks as
if subsets of the system are independent
from each other but also tracking each
other then you know you yeah you get
this interesting uh Behavior like the if
there is this markup like it is if there
is this independent structure then you
will get this tracking Behavior that's
what the free energy principle is
talking about so of course it's not
sufficient to say uh that things are
carved out in a specific way and
therefore you know you can say
interesting things about them uh but I
think what's missed in the argument uh
and this has to do with like you know I
think the the op the the the
I'll stay provocatively the the dogmatic
commitment to anti-representationalism
is like what when the inactivist's
regenerative model they mean a model in
my head that I carry around they hear
like a representation right the the but
what's really at stake is the generative
model is the dependency structure right
so if you have the right kind of
dependency structure that generates a
Markov blanket I would say that you have
what the inactivists call operational
closure uh in fact you can show this
mathematically it's I don't think it's
appreciated but um there is a duality uh
that has been rigorously established
daltonville is probably the main
proponent of the this work but you know
Carl has done a lot of work over the
last two decades in this direction
um yeah I think the uh the kind of core
idea to uh remember is that
minimizing your variational entropy with
your variational free energy with
respect to a generative model right so
the usual free energy story right is
dual two or equivalent to maximizing
your entropy with respect to a set of
constraints
so when the inactivists talk about
constraint closure and all this stuff
you know uh Alicia gerrero's new uh book
uh context changes everything the
inactivists in in the auto poetic
tradition really want to go hard on this
and say well what you really need to do
is map a set of constraints such that
the system kind of self-generates well
that is rigorously and absolutely
equivalent to minimizing your free
energy with respect to a generative
model there's no difference there so
we're talking about the same thing we're
talking about the way that like a set of
structured dependencies generates a
thing that's able to sustain itself over
time and as I was saying this this
sustained over time is a way of
describing the interface or coupling
between the system and its environment
so the just mathematically we're talking
about the same thing uh let me but let
me ask you a question here because
there's and this is hopefully because I
like Carl I want to find out if I'm in
an activist so maybe maybe you can help
set us up for considering this a big
bone of contention for them in that
paper is this distinction that they have
in their mind between structure and
organization and they seem to get upset
when any attempt is made to link
organization to structure for example if
you know to me the Markov boundary that
say analogous to a um a uh animal cell
membrane I understand as a former person
who studied biology that the molecules
of that membrane are in flux things come
and go proteins are added carbohydrates
are removed et cetera I don't have in my
mind a set of molecules that's like
there forever and some type of like you
know
stationary structure like it's a very
Dynamic kind of system but they seem to
say oh no if you equip if you equate you
know a Markov boundary to an
organizational structure then you're
making this you know fallacy of kind
where you're associating like an
organization with like the substrate
that you know manifests that in reality
like can you explain to me like what
they were actually up in arms about with
this organization versus structure you
know maybe Carl if you could comment on
it when Maxwell tells us so we can
figure out if we're an activist so I'll
uh just let me bracket the stuff about
stationarity and historicity for one
second uh because I have some stuff to
say about that
um but so it comes we'll come back to
that we'll come back to that because I
have a question about that it comes back
to what I was saying about about you
know it's not just about Markov blankets
it's about generative models if you
don't appreciate the distinction and
what you think we're saying is Markov
blankets tell the whole story then
obviously you're gonna you know think
that we're conflating structure and
organization when you realize that what
we're talking about is uh you know a
Markov blanket within this dependency
structure right then I think you you
move to something else I would say like
what the inactivists call structure
corresponds to these Markov blankets
that we're drawing and the organization
we talk about and we harness in the
generative model right remember the
generative model is not my internal
representation in my head it's the
overall dependency structure of the
system it's what they would call the
organization of the system so I mean I
would agree that we shouldn't conflate
them and I would you know add that we
don't uh that there are distinct
constructs that map onto these things
um and you know I would also point out
that Marco blankets are flexible
um we uh we'll be putting out uh work uh
over the next few months on uh wandering
Markov blankets like we've got that
figured out algorithmically now we uh
can draw a blanket around a flame and
stuff like that now so we've got all of
that working uh and it's not I've been
looking forward to that since Carl
mentioned it in the the first the first
interview with him let's let's um we'll
set an anchor to come back to that
because that's very interesting actually
one comment you made in in your
multi-scale paper was that these are
ontological boundaries by which I think
you are implying that they are not a
lens they are fixed to some extent but I
want to just stick on on this um
organization point for a second though
so in in the paper they said that
um essentially the way the fep couches
this is a is as a form of homeostasis
which is just about you know maintaining
structural properties and when they
spoke about organization they said the
conservation of organization is what's
spoken about in the Classic Auto poetic
literature and I think you were just
making the argument Maxwell that that
generative model is in some sense the
conservation of organization so is that
the missing link I mean maybe a
professor Kristen you can come in
yeah do you want to take that Carl I
mean I think that's right but Carl will
probably uh comment more eloquently than
eye on that I don't think so you're
being very eloquent thank you do your
worst and then I'll I'll check in if
necessary
um
yeah I mean I I think that's that's
exactly right like the Markov blankets
don't have to be
um permanent uh they they can be
shifting and uh basically minimizing
your free energy with respect to some
generative model corresponds to keeping
some structure in play
um yeah actually this segue is nicely
into the stuff about stationarity and
historicity uh I think this is the
biggest problem in their paper
um they claim that the free energy
principle can't account for historicity
uh in the sense that it can't account
for path dependency right so for our
audience path dependency is this idea
that it's not just your position in
state space that matters it's also your
velocity roughly speaking right that
like the the kind of direction that
you're going in where you came from is
just as important to where you're going
as where you are currently
um and they claim that you know the free
energy so they make a bunch of false
claims about the free energy principle
which leads them astray so for example
they claim that the free energy
principle uh assumes stationarity it
doesn't uh as we've discussed before
there are different applications of the
free energy principle in the literature
the two main families of applications
are um density Dynamics and path
integrals
um so I drink a lot of coffee
and if you were to sample me at random
during the day I would say there's a 1
in 25 chance yeah exactly I would say
there's a 1 in 25 chance that I'm
drinking coffee if you just sample me
randomly during the day uh if you were
to sample me uh over a week once per day
there's a 100 chance that I would drink
coffee per day right so there's a
difference between looking at the
probability of states of me you know
Maxwell is drinking coffee and the
probabilities of Paths of me or entire
trajectories of me
um and that is a really critical
distinction
um the free energy principle started off
as a path-based formulation and I think
this is absolutely underappreciated in
the literature if you look back at
Carl's early papers including the ones
that everyone has read right the 2010 uh
unified brain Theory paper in nature
um yeah these are all written in terms
of paths Carl is taking like a sensory
path and then writing down you know
blanket paths and internal paths and
it's all it's all about
um the way the trajectories of the
system are maintained so this is a cool
idea that was there before and that
we're doubling back down on now uh which
is that it's really it's about blanket
paths that make internal paths
independent of external paths so there's
a sense in which like it's always been
about counterfactual Futures it's and
it's difficult to argue that like you
don't account for historicity when
literally the core construct that you're
deploying is
like probabilities of different
histories like counterfactual Futures
but that entire argument about a
historicity makes no sense formally just
absolutely I you know and again we
appreciate the critical engagement this
isn't to you know bash anyone
specifically but like this is a complete
non-starter mathematically also
um when you're doing density Dynamics
right when you're not considering
probability densities over paths but
rather you're considering probabilities
of states and you're doing this
non-equilibrium steady state stuff so
when you are assuming stationarity
you're saying like yeah there are these
kind of regular cyclical behaviors that
I want to model even in that context the
free energy principle can handle path
dependence like literally I think on
page 12 of like Carl's monograph of 2019
on the density Dynamics formulations
there are already terms that contain you
know Expressions that are able to handle
path dependency that are basically
dependent on changes in surprise in your
system so so before we before we move
too far maybe Chris you can you might be
able to steal man what the the paper was
trying to say there or it might not
being generous enough
well I'm just I'm just I'm trying to I'm
trying to decide if I'm in an activist
because stem's a big fan so I want to
you know give it fair to anyone does
anybody want a steel man you know where
the paper might have been coming from in
terms of this argument against
historicity
I can straw man it if you want no all
right I'm happy to have a go with that
but I mean so uh we're a very broad
church at um uh within this community we
we debate within ourselves about uh that
you know the the true Origins and how we
get these things out so I actually uh
was worried about this historicity thing
uh uh in an earlier version we did in uh
we published in physics or life reviews
with it with a student a very talented
student of mine and we we found real
problems with it when we were in a
state-based formulation of the system
and I know Maxwell uh feels that even
the state-based description of
probability density is that we can
recover historicity I guess we we're
still not complete agreement on that but
the what what's majorly happened in the
in the three energies this movement to
pass and I agreed Maxwell if you go back
into Carl's original work talking like
uh Carlos is not here but if you're back
to Carl's original work he was framing
it in terms terms of pass but the
presentations in the monograph were to
do to do with States and when we worked
through that we found it that the
historicity was hard to to to get back
into these systems but the path
formalization then makes it clear how
historicity because it's built into the
system because you're preserving sets of
paths you go to you know uh home your
recess rather than homeostasis in the
descriptions of these systems and then
there's this kind of nice elegant uh way
to deal with historicity and you know
and I think so I I don't think that's a
a real issue with the free energy
principle so but I can imagine I don't
know what technical literature they've
they've read but perhaps if they've read
the state-based formula formulation they
had the same worries about us about
historicity and if they read these new
um pathway stuff that
um Maxwell and Dalton are developing I
think that was kind of uh dissolve I
think that it's a much richer framework
now
so maybe Carl um what were you thinking
back then when you did it as paths you
know maybe just give us uh some some
thought behind your intuition for why
you originally formulated it as you know
path path integrals for past systems and
you know what your perspective is on
what we've been discussing so far
right
um I can't really remember
um I suppose you know the obvious answer
is much of this inherits from Richard
fireman's work on the path integral
formulation indeed the variational free
energy can be traced uh right back to I
think probably his PhD thesis I haven't
actually read the PHD thesis but I've
been shown all the maths you need is
there
um so it would be difficult for me to
conceive of a calculus that wasn't
framed in terms of
um in terms of paths until you start to
try and draw graphics and explain to
people who are not familiar
um with um you know with the notion or
you know with the pattern formulation
and its equivalence with
um density Dynamics as articulated say
with the vocaplank equation or I repeat
sort of call McGruff forward and
backward equations
um so I think that is
um
you know that's one really important
aspect of historicity
um and becomes I think even more
prescient when you think about deploying
a pathogable form a formulation of
self-organization in the context of 21st
century physics that's what we're
talking about now is a move away from
20th century equilibrium physics with
point attractors to open systems that
are far from equilibrium so
mathematically
um or one mathematical bright line
between the physics of equilibria and
the physics of non-equilibria which is
what the free energy principle is about
or specifically
um when
um non-equilibrium
State Solutions admit a Markov blanket
but returning to the sort of what is
definitive of non-equilibria it is
effectively the
um not the historicity but the the the
the
um
the itinerancy you get from solenoidal
Dynamics sort of conservative dynamics
that now supplement the dissipative
flows that characterize completely
classical physics and equilibrium
um equilibria steady state so so if you
wanted to define the difference between
an open system or an outer equilibrium
or a non-equilibrium system from an
equilibrium system the simple kind of
systems that Chris was referring to in
his you know
toy models of your desert free energy
principle work in you know in this kind
of system
um then all you would do is write down
um the Dynamics in terms of dissipative
and conservative or non-disivative
Divergence free components and that if
you like decomposition of the flow into
conservative and dissipative parts is
just the how those decomposition it's
just the fundamental element of
variational calculus I think
um or fundamental theorem
um which just says that you know any
flow any Dynamics
um can always be decomposed into this
sort of gradient descent that
underwrites classical physics or
equilibrium physics
um and the a solenoidal Divergence free
flow that underwrites classical
mechanics but you put the two together
and you have by definition now
um a a mathematical image of
non-equilibrium systems and notice that
in introducing this kind of itinerancy
that
um
is for example uh you know heuristically
you know water going down a plug hole so
the dissipative part the gradient flow
would be the the uh the Water tumbling
down into the depths of your house but
as it circulates around
the um technically in in terms of the
information theory around on ISO
Contours the probability distribution
but you know you can just visualize the
water circular that's the solenoidal
part and of course when you talk about
biotic self-organization or
self-organization
um
non-equilibria that has that sort of
life like our biotic form the the the
key characteristic of this kind of
biotic circulation is basically rhythms
and life cycles
um so the very fact you're dealing with
um this kind of uh historicity that is
inherent in the itinerancy of any system
that is not at equilibrium means that
you are you have to how write down
um or have an understanding or a
mathematics that deals with these with
these flows and these life cycles just
one little interesting twist here is if
you take the randomness out of this if
you go back to deterministic dynamical
systems of the kind I Now understand
underwrote the the split or the fork in
the road in philosophy
um what you do is you're basically
removing from the perspective of the
helmhurst decomposition the dissipative
part and you just left with the
conservative part what is that that's
just new turning mechanics it says
classical mechanics which is why the sun
we rotate around the Sun or the moon
takes these orbits this is just this
solenoidal flow in the limit that you've
ignored the randomness that you need
that
calls for the information theoretical
probabilistic descriptions you know of
any world so that the free energy
principle doesn't deal with all kinds of
systems it deals with um systems that
have an admixture of both the
dissipative and the solenoidal or
Divergence free Parts if you wanted to
just do the dissipated Parts you do
quantum mechanics if you just wanted to
do the solenoidal part you do classical
mechanics and deterministic systems but
in the middle you're you know in the
Goldilocks regime in which you and I
operate we're talking about stochastic
chaos basically another description of
this itinerancy so I think that that's
that's you know one aspect of
historicity which I you know is
celebrated in the physics of
self-organization
um and I keep using the word
self-organization because I read
autoparesis as self-creation or at least
self-maintenance uh I now appreciate
it's not quite self
um it's bit slightly Beyond
self-maintenance and and and
um in the sense that you know to create
um you know imply something slightly
greater and that may be
um I'm gonna have to ask Chris um it may
be related to operational closure so I'd
like to if something just described for
me and the audience what operational
closure is that would be quite nice but
before you do
um there is another important aspect of
historicity uh which we haven't
mentioned which inherits from
um the deployment of the free energy
principle or perhaps just the hell
that's decomposition
um in using the apparatus of the
renormalization group and what that
brings to the table is a separation of
temporal scale fields and as soon as you
have that in play there's a different
kind of historicity which you you have
to accommodate in any given calculus
certainly for open systems which means
that the the kind of steady state
solutions that are non-equilibrium
steady set Solutions we are talking
about in the context of the pathogical
formulation
um only exist over a certain time scale
there's always a time scale above that
contextualizes it and there's always a
time scale below that is much much
faster where things live for a very very
short periods of time and I think that's
another important aspect of historicity
that we're not talking about a unique or
privileged time scale here so when
people talk about stationarity or
ergidicity or
steady States
um
they you know one cannot say that this
is the configuration of a system at T
equals infinity
you know because you have to acknowledge
that there is no preparation time skills
and at this time scale we will assume
there is a solid state solution but we
have to be very explicit at this time
scale and this does not apply at the
time scale above or the time scale below
and interestingly just mathematically it
well perhaps a naive mathematical or
something a physicist mathematical
perspective
um the very fact you have the separation
of time scale basically means that there
are factors fast stuff or fast Dynamics
and slow Dynamics and at the end of the
day if you now consider what is the
difference between
the flow of states that you would find
in a deterministic ground and a
deterministic dynamical system and the
random fluctuations are converted into a
random dynamical system the only
difference between these things is
whether they're fast or slow so you can
treat the random fluctuations the noise
that induces a probabilistic description
and all the information thematic
treatments as simply the fast things and
everything else is the slow stuff so
again speaking to if you like an almost
necessary connection
um between any dynamical systems
formulation that is sufficiently liberal
to include fast and slow stuff and the
probabilistic treatments of that of the
kind that Richard fireman pursued in in
terms of trying to work out the
probability of the path of the small
particle or electron for his PhD thesis
anyway what is operational closure
if you wanted me to read it out can I
just frame you up there Chris because in
in that forking paper there was I
actually thought it was a little bit um
hand wavy it's not like in graph Theory
where you have very kind of precise
definitions so they had a they had a um
a kind of a node diagram and they said
it was operationally closed if all of
the black colored nodes had one Arrow
going out and connecting to another one
and they had a kind of diagram just
showing a an organism but what's the
official definition Chris
yeah so this is a definition from Varela
it says an automotive system is that is
their organization is characterized by
processors such that the processes are
related as a network so that recursively
depend on each other in the generation
realization of the processes themselves
and two they constitute the system as a
Unity recognizable in space uh in which
those processes exist so it's kind of
this deep recursive recursivity between
the processes maintaining the networks
as necessary for the processes this kind
of generation of the system's own
constraints and I guess this has been
it's always been a kind of slightly
ineffable within the auto literature
what this means formally right there's a
deep intuition this is correct you know
you think about uh as a key said before
where the the matter is changing as as
flux is uh changing these processes but
the identities somehow staying the same
and that's the organizational structure
that's maintained over time rather than
the material uh components of that of
that structure and I do think you know
that there is a sense there was some
when we did focus on these uh
state-based descriptions of the free
energy principle I think that kind of
undersold the solenoidal flow that um
Carl was talking about wears that is I
think it's much more important to the
people in in in in Auto places because
this notion of of this kind of flow of
information and the organization is
dynamic within the equilibrium is
important for for that field so I think
that you know the new directions they've
got in the free entry principle things
like Maxwell and Dalton are pursuing is
to me an exciting opportunity to kind of
reconcile some of the ineffability of
these operational closure ideas uh in
Auto voices and this framework
essentially
cool cool so um do you want to comment
maybe briefly on on that before we move
on like uh because Chris Chris called
out some of your work there with Dalton
yeah I mean uh in a good way though I
think what Chris is saying is that he
agrees with the direction I I would just
say that this isn't really new work in
the sense that what Dalton and I are
just doing is extending work that Carl
did toward almost 20 years ago uh so I
see this as more continuous uh you know
someone might say that I'm being overly
generous which I might be you know by
looking at this as like one kind of
continuous development uh but yeah I I
don't really I I think uh you know you
can think of the state based description
it's sort of the asymptotic limit of the
path based description the two are kind
of like deeply uh connected uh in in
some sense
um
so no I mean uh I I think this is real
this is the direction that we want to go
there's still some interesting stuff
that you can say using the density
Dynamics formulation uh we just have to
be you know it's like we were discussing
uh Keith during our mlst uh interview uh
last time this is mine physics right so
you know a a Hallmark of physics is
idealization and so you know necessarily
some of these constructs are going to be
uh you know the map has to be simpler
than the territory it's like we were
saying right you know otherwise you get
you wind up in a borehass novel with
like uh you know a map the size of Los
Angeles that you can't use uh so uh you
know for certain kinds of oscillatory
cyclical biobehaviors the
non-equilibrium steady state is a
perfectly fine uh you know uh model of
it uh you know uh I I drink coffee so
regularly that it might as well be like
you know deterministic and like you know
orbiting the Sun kind of thing um so you
know this speaks to the fact that the
free energy principle is what it says on
the tin it's a principle it's a it's a
that leads to a modeling method
um and you know uh we make some
assumptions uh and we're able to say
some things uh but the principle itself
doesn't rest on on any of these
assumptions
um like stationarity uh for example like
you don't really need that to get it to
get it working all you need is a markout
blanket in your random dynamical system
and you're sort of ready to go
um in terms of like the formalization of
uh the inactive approach I always saw
this uh so like Chris by the way I think
this is under I I don't talk about it
very much but much like Chris I started
off recalcitrant to the free energy
principle I I found out about this stuff
in around 2014 and it it you know like I
said I was trained as an activist and
this really conflicted with my
intuitions and I went into this thinking
I I I need to uh and this is also what I
think the spear spirit that motivates a
lot of criticism you go into this
thinking I need to understand this just
enough to be able to to know for sure
that I don't need to understand this
actually and you know you go into this
and I you know I remember having like a
conversion experience reading um Carl's
2012 entropy paper called a free energy
principle for biological systems which
was a path-based kind of formulation and
everything and really you know seeing oh
wow like there's no there's no resisting
this like this is inevitable and really
getting like oh yeah this is an
inevitable consequence of physics isn't
it like there's no there's no getting
around this uh and then kind of you know
doubling down in my conversion and then
becoming a part of the community
um so what's funny is I had the opposite
experience of you two so I when I first
saw it I'm like this is amazing like
this is exactly how it works and now
I've been trying to escape ever since
you know I don't like being Shackled
like to the free energy principle and
funny enough we've talked before about
how you know Carl that the free energy
principle is one of the few principles
that applies to itself it's like as
simple as it as it can be and still and
still work the other aspect in which
that's true is as we've been talking
about it maintains this flexibility or
maybe vagueness you know the critics
might say but it maintains this
flexibility which leads to it inevitably
generating all kinds of controversy and
debates you know and people arguing
about like the limits of that
flexibility right one thing I would
quickly point out is like uh there's
this sense I think in the literature
that there are like 17 different
possible interpretations of the free
energy principle and that you can make
me say one thing and it's opposite right
what I've been going around saying is no
that's not correct there's only the free
energy principle and it has the
implications that it does uh and there
are misinterpretations of the free
energy principle uh so for example you
know I think this idea that some people
in the literature have been uh pushing
that like the free energy Prince is even
compatible with this kind of radical
anti-realism this kind of uh you know uh
like a Descartes demon kind of thing uh
that's not that just doesn't follow it's
it's incompatible with the math like the
you need you need there to be an actual
world out there to couple to you for the
math to get off the ground so there
there actually isn't a bunch of
different interpretations there's just
the free energy principle it's just that
it's a lens that make use makes you see
that a lot of the dichotomies that used
to structure the way we think about
things are false uh this comes back to
the thing that we were discussing at the
end of our interview Keith uh this is
sort of like a uh you know you're sort
of abolishing the distinction between
the super lunar Ray and the sub lunari
spheres right so classical mechanics uh
abolishes the the distinction that was
popular in Scholastic philosophy which
was you know like a thousand a thousand
five hundred years of like you know uh
natural philosophy saying well I mean if
you look at the way things behave the
things out there beyond the moon in the
Supra lunary sphere right they move in
perfect orbits perfect circles uh seems
to have nothing to do with you know
things here that fall to the ground or
rise and have a beginning a middle and
an end these seem like radically
distinct spheres of reality but then
Newton comes along in classical
mechanics equips you with a set of
equations that apply equally to things
here and things over there thereby just
abolishing that distinction and I think
like the free energy principle comes
around and does undoes a lot of these
false dichotomies in the same way like
we were talking about internalism versus
externalism it allows you to say yeah
there's something to the internalist
story the internal states are doing
something special but you actually need
the external world to be there to get
the story to kind of pick up so I think
you get a lot of this uh
and I guess my hot take is that uh the
inactivists need there to be a bright
line in the universe like a bright red
line uh on the one and then what's on
each side of the line depends on the
inactivist right so like uh but the
story is always something like there's
physics there's mere physics on one side
and then there's the interesting stuff
on the other side there's biology or
maybe there's mind or there's something
like that and there is this bright red
line like yeah uh
Maxwell's saying the free energy
principle is the ultimate shade of gray
I hope you uh
well no I know Tim we wanted to move to
a new topic Yeah Yeah well yeah I mean
that there's a few things to touch on
that means certainly the the philosophy
of um uh you know an activism versus
ecological psychology is an interesting
one because with an activism we get
quite a few um uh philosophical things
um bagged on that possibly we we may or
may not want for example the
phenomenology the existentialism which
is this idea that you can shape your own
experience this kind of Eastern
philosophy which is that in some sense
There's no distinction between you and
your environment and it has been
criticized as being quite ill-defined
and vague but
um I think Maxwell you have said that
there's much more of a tighter
compatibility with ecological psychology
and that's essentially that we see the
world through affordances and what that
means is that we see the world as
trajectories of actions in our physical
environment that we live in and
philosophically that's a realist
ontology so that means there are no
representations we're taking actions in
the real world and we know that the real
world exists and now many cognitive
science people of course resist to this
notion because they say we need to have
representations and then we get to this
interesting discussion that we're having
about this kind of Continuum between
this idea that on the one hand there are
no representations if we are gibsonian
and we are ecology magical psychologists
um but on on the other hand
um we might need to have increasing
levels of representation if we actually
have this temporal depth if we have
these nested
um Markov boundaries and we are
sophisticated Minds that are making
predictions into the future now with
that laid out I wanted to talk about
this notion of goals now in a
externalist inactivist framework I think
that goals are not something we should
explicitly Define now when you speak
with go-fi people when they talk about
building cognitive architectures they
say that goals should be explicitly
crafted into the architecture at least
that's what they would have said 20
years ago now they're slightly more
refined and they say well we should have
a gold module in the architecture but
the goals should be acquired empirically
and there should be sub goals and and so
on now if I understand correctly we were
just talking about the free energy
principle it has this notion of paths
and we have beliefs over trajectories of
actions into the future and to what
extent is a belief a goal because if if
if you have an almost infinite number of
beliefs so there's a trajectory to this
future state where I'm rich but there's
also an infinitude of other potential
trajectories and they are of course
constrained by the physical afford
senses and trajectories that I can take
in my physical environment that seems
different to having an intention of
wanting to be rich or wanting to play
tennis because I'm constrained in all of
these different ways so yeah why didn't
we just talk about the dichotomy between
beliefs and goals
uh I I think Carl or Chris would be
better equipped to answer the latter
question Carl in particular has been
thinking about intentional Behavior
quite deeply recently uh I did want to
quickly comment upon ecological
psychology uh I have been um saying to
the ecosite community that uh Bayesian
mechanics and ecosyc are the same
discipline
they're really it's the same thing uh
Vicente Raja is one of the uh cooler uh
more technically proficient people in
the ecosite community and uh after you
know a few years of back and forth we've
realized that yeah we're using exactly
the same set of mathematical tools the
only framing is a the only difference is
a philosophical framing is uh are you an
indirectist or a directist right so and
I I happen to think that these are just
kind of semantic cribbles if you look at
the more contemporary Eco psych
literature so the ecosite people are
tend to be much more sophisticated
technically than the inactive people and
one thing that they have in common is
that they don't reject information
Theory out of hand they want the Richer
notion of information like ecological
information or semantic information some
kind of information that has some
relevance to the environment uh you know
the the organisms like uh Emilia it's
it's umvelt it's it's world of Life uh
but they're not rejecting information
theory in fact uh Gibson's original
ambition was to apply physics to the
study of perception just straight up uh
you know so it's all about like you know
energy the the energy on the perceptual
arrays and all of this stuff it's
essentially I think the same project
from a methodological and mathematical
perspective the main difference is just
a an enacted an ecological psychologist
sorry would say that we perceive things
directly
uh but then they appeal to this these
Notions of like resonance and whatever
which you know to us is just a synonym
for inference I I guess it's like it the
difference rests in like are you
centering on the the internal
perspective of an organism or are you
looking at things as a multi-scale stack
with the organism kind of carving out
one level uh so we had a great session
actually with Michael Anderson's uh
emerge lab group uh based out of uh
Ontario and my my gut tells me that
there will be uh a um a kind of
strategic Alliance and maybe even just a
merging of these two Fields uh moving
forward uh yeah and you know for the
more cynical part of me thinks that the
the merger of free energy principle and
ecosite gives you everything that you
might want out of inactivism but without
any of the you know heavy kind of
metaphysical or philosophical baggage
that seems to be you know hindering
progress in that field
so that's my thing about Eco psych uh
okay maybe we can bring you Chris in on
on the the goals thing so it's it's a
goal an end state is it a trajectory is
it a bearing and is it is it does it
exist explicitly in the externalist view
of cognition
well so I'm a kind of more of a
practical computational person so I I
leave the philosophy to Maxwell but I
mean I I tend to take the intentional
stats intentional stance on systems
where if we can just if it makes sense
for us to describe a system as a goal
directed then we should do so and if
that helps Engineers to build those
systems then they they should do so
right but there's a nice kind of uh
there's a nice parallel between uh those
are kind of ideas and the original work
in cybernetics so there's the you know
the good regulator theorem which this
kind of early work by Common and Ashby
suggests that any any control system of
a given environment is a good model of
the environment it's that it controls
just by by necessity from first
principles right which to me which would
suggest that we should in principle be
able to describe uh an intentional
structure uh in terms of the kind of
generative model uh within within the
system we should be able to find it if
it is a good control system and it
should exist I think there's also a more
practical thing about shifting from a
notion of reward God as this kind of
potential function that's kind of
dominated the machine learning area
right so we have this kind of Monolithic
thing called reward and everything is in
in service of that reward to a richer
notion of beliefs about Dynamics which
which affords that kind of uh you know
moves away that potential function to a
more kind of dynamical system so we can
get more kind of Rich beliefs about
future trajectories and and so on and we
know that in control systems that's
really it's really important right if we
wanted to control the system we're doing
model based control we have to have
desires on the futures of those systems
we need to understand the trajectory and
the Divergence of the trajectories over
Through Time right so I think it's a
much richer picture practically to think
about uh you know beliefs about Dynamics
rather than uh reward and I think
there's this nice parallel between the
intentional structure and the good
regulator Theory because I think the
good regulatory ethereum entails that we
should find those kind of intentional
Dynamics within our systems right with
that just by a priori first reasoning so
yeah I just want to know if he could
explain the good regulator ethereum
because I think that yes
is really strong resonances with this
and I think you know there was a long it
was a long time uh not Carl the Carl's
excluded for us a long time the people
who were reading the free energy
literature to think that the kind of the
roots of the free energy principle was
in helmholtz homeholstering perception
right this notion the Bayesian inference
and perception but there's kind of a
much richer reading to see its roots in
in cybernetics movement and particularly
by The Works of people like Ross Ashby
and so on so he's basically said uh he
provided this fear into that showed that
if you want to build a regulator for a
given environmental system that
optimally regulates that system then it
necessitates that regulator is a good
model of that system right and there's a
kind of you can take that kind of in a
strong way and a weak way and we we
worried about this for a long time but
just to diffuse that from its
representational kind of implications
which we worried about for a long time
you can see this in something like even
like the what governor which is used
this is classic uh an activist system
that doesn't is non-representationalist
but there are kind of uh there is a
sense in which the Dynamics of the
governor needs to mirror the
fluctuations of the the steam engine
it's regulating and it's that kind of
coupling and that kind of uh reflection
of those Dynamics which is important uh
for the regulation of that system right
so that kind of you can back out that I
you know I think this is very nice align
with the intentional stance and demands
uh an intentional stance if you if you
if you if you if you're committed to
this notion of the good regulator
theorem to rip on your point of the
intentional Sun I think that that's a
fascinating way of looking at it um
Chris and to bring you in Professor
Bristol so um Professor Daniel Dennett
had this notion of the intentional
stance
that um when we you know we we
essentially have a mental model of the
intentions of other agents and we use
that to understand their behavior and an
intention is a goal if you think about
it it's something I want to do but in
this dynamical systems framework it's
not explicitly coded anywhere it kind of
emerges and of course it's a subjective
state so we've spoken about mental
phenomenal States being encoded in our
generative model in our in our free
energy framework and those States will
of course have
um intentional
um you know representations of the other
agents that we're dealing with so I
guess just the question back to you
Professor friston how do goals kind of
get encoded in in this Dynamics
yeah that's a great question I I know
the answer you want because you don't
like girls do you oh
well I don't mind if they're I I guess
the answer is they're emergent which is
which is yeah I was groping for that yes
they have to you know
you have to find a physics where it
looks as if there are girls and they
emerge from a particular kind of
self-organization and I think that's
that's been beautifully Illustrated just
in the in the previous conversations
you've had
um you know ranging from
um the work of uh Russ Ashby on his
homeostat which I think would be better
nowadays called an allostat but if we
just stick with the homeostat because
you know does homeostasis have a goal do
does my physiology have the goal of
maintaining my temperature at 37 degrees
Centigrade it said it looks like that do
I intend to do that well
um I think on one reading of intention
yes uh yeah
um and certainly on an allostatic
um reading of
um behaviors that have this temporal
depth and are the consequence of plans
into the future you know putting turning
on the thermostat or putting on clothes
I think then you're you're getting much
closer to this sort of more
anthropomorphic notion of intentionality
whether I think there are girls there
are there are end points
um so
I guess that the question then
um is you know at what point would these
different kinds of intentionality a
girl-directed behavior emerge from
self-organization
um and in which what particular kinds of
systems would you expect to see this
these these these behaviors I think
there's some fairly straightforward
answers from the point of view of the
physicists not not the philosopher
um so if you just look at the different
kinds of systems that you could apply
and the free energy principle too
um we've talked about one of them um
right at the beginning when considering
Markov blankets that did not have any
have any internal States for example a
stone yeah so every state of this thing
is just a Markov blanket and it is in
reciprocal exchange with the external
States
um so that would be when the internal
states are empty what are there other
kinds of systems that you could have
well you could imagine systems that
didn't have any active States
um but you know
um most interesting systems do have
active States and then you ask about the
relative contribution of these random
fluctuations to the Dynamics you know
the self-organization and if you just
follow the maths through
um the path integral in particular
um maths of the Dynamics that any system
at a particular temporal scale must have
if it's internal or autonomous Dynamics
um or the Dynamics the flows of the
internal States and the uh the blanket
states that constitute a particle or a
person when they become sufficiently
precise so when we get become big enough
um and cool enough so let's assume that
we're we're we're big we're bigger than
a Quantum scale but not too big to
become classical so not the size of the
moon but we are roughly your size of my
size no perhaps the size of a mouse or
an insect shooter to an elephant or a
giraffe
um then you have uh this interesting
situation of these very precise Dynamics
and they're precise just because we are
big so all the random fluctuations are
averaged away
in this particular case then you can Dem
you can show that these particular kinds
of things or mark off blankets
um have a very well defined probability
distribution over paths into the future
specifically the paths of the active
States so let's assume that there are
certain kinds of particles or creatures
um that have active States and they have
um you know
um they and the blanket States in Shroud
a sufficient number of internal States
what would they look like if they had
very precise Dynamics well you can
actually work out the probability
distribution over the active states that
over their actions over their movements
and these could be physiological
movements so autonomic reflexes they
could be physical movements eye
movements or
um perambulatory movements or indeeding
them talking
um and it transpires the the the the
um the probability distribution over
these particular Paths of active States
has an interesting functional form when
written in terms of the potential or the
log probability and we call that
expected free energy
um and that expected free energy when
you just write it down
um passes into or com can be decomposed
into things that um people have been
dealing with for uh centuries
um uh specifically
um the expected Information Gain and the
expected reward or utility where reward
or utility is scored by the
um the log probability of occupying an
attractive state or rewarding State and
I use the word attractive State
deliberately because it is just part of
the pullback attractor that
um affords the application of
um the you know the pathogen formulation
um it's just the characteristic States
this kind of thing occupies so the the
goalness if you like is it is um
inherent in the characteristics of the
particle or person that you're trying to
describe so for certain kinds of
particles or persons then it will
certainly look as if they are acting
with long-term Vision namely planning in
a way to return themselves to their
attracting set which you could look you
could now regard as a goal or a rewarded
or at least an attracting and attracting
outcome or um
or or state of being so I think that
kind of particle starts to now show the
the Deep intention you know it looks as
if they are into they are doing this
because they're intense some outcome I
think the next step though which is the
one that you were speaking to possibly
danden it was implying is another I
think step which is but does the does
the internal State know that you know am
I aware that I am planning
um and of course that calls upon very
very sophisticated so if they exist
um internal or generative models that
entail a model of me and the hypothesis
that all of this these Sensations and
all the consequences of my actions which
I am not aware of
um you know I I cannot feel all the
um
sensory not Century all the neuronal
impulses that cause my muscles to
contract all I can register is the
consequences of that through my muscle
my stretch receptors my proprioceptor
receptors or if it's in my gut or my
autonomic interceptive receptors so I
don't know what I'm I can't I can't have
I do have have no access to my actual
action but I can see the consequences of
it and it looks as if I'm planning so I
now have a hypothesis a fantasy that I
am a thing and I seem to have goals and
if I can learn the kinds of goals that I
have then I can now start to mentalize
and have Notions in my genitive model
about my goals and then I notice oh you
have goals or perhaps it's the other way
around perhaps first of all it looks as
if the explanation for this random
dynamical system over here called Mom is
actually but she looks as though she
plans it looks as if she has goals and
then a few years later if I develop a
sense of self well perhaps have a thing
like mum and that perhaps I have goals
so I think that you're you're from the
point of view of dandenet's intentional
stance I think we're talking about a
very very particular kind of system
um that actually has this capacity to
recognize first of all intentional like
behaviors long-term planning Dynamics in
other conspices or things like itself
off and then actually transcribe that
and test the hypothesis or perhaps I
have a thing like that as well perhaps
I'm me perhaps yeah
and what's beautiful about what you just
said there and all three of you have
said this in different different ways so
I want to dwell on this just a bit
because I think it's a source of the
misunderstanding and or controversy
about the free energy principles so
earlier Maxwell you had said you know
it's really a model about the couplings
and and the isolations together the
couplings and the decouplings and the
Dynamics between them uh you know Carl
you just said
systems will behave as if
they had intentions whether or not they
really have intentions or not is kind of
a different philosophical question but
they'll behave as if they had intentions
and Chris you brought up you know the
watt Governor which is it's it's
obviously a very simple dynamic system
you know spending centrifuge and you
know arm bar like whatever else and yet
it's it's not as though it's a literal
model in the sense that I'm going to
have a Mathematica a mathematical model
for what the steam engine is doing but
it's behaving as if it were an effective
model of the steam engine because hey
when it's slightly out of sync the arm
flexes a little bit it readjusts it's
you know the spin changes slightly
things continue to work because if it
didn't have the Dynamics that were as if
it had a model the thing wouldn't
function it would just fall apart so I
guess what we're all what's all being
said here is that systems at different
scales will behave as if they had a
model even if they don't necessarily
have a model in the sense of a person
like a person might have a conscious
model from which they develop a plan or
whatnot but all these systems of varying
scales and complexities still behave as
if they had a model they act to minimize
the free energy as a consequence of you
know being random dynamical systems that
are self-maintaining
yeah I think that's a really eloquently
put and actually that so this is this to
kind of underwrites some of the worries
we had about the the principle when we
first started walking uh working on it
as kind of coming from an activist or a
low low road an activist this notion of
kind of a an explicit
representationalism that you can you can
get in these models where the model is a
homomorphic with the environment right
and that doesn't doesn't it rankles
people who've come from behavior-based
Robotics and stuff like this but then to
kind of realize that there's a this it's
a richer relationship between the
internal external that's being mirrored
right it doesn't have to be this uh
homomorphic mapping and also the you
know the actions are deeply involved in
carving out the world that you represent
you live in your umvelt uh you're a
model of your own belt you're a model of
regulating your ownvelt which is not in
you know it's not just like this static
separation of the of the agent from its
environment there's this deep coupling
which uh which can you know which these
kind of mirrorings emerge from but yeah
I think you you articulated it really
well there
any any comments yeah
no I think you did a great job I agree
with Chris like that yeah
so I think we've got about 15 minutes
left so we'll we'll do two more topics
we'll end on structural learning and the
Practical implementations of the free
energy principle but I just wanted to
touch on what you were talking about
earlier Maxwell which is this notion of
the boundaries being potentially vague
or maybe even Observer relative now in
your multi-scale paper you did say use
the word ontological boundaries I think
um and I also wanted to talk about
meaning so there's the boundaries of
cognition in the physical world so we
have this dynamical system and it kind
of converges and we've got these nested
kind of hierarchy of of boundaries but
then in a kind of denit sense meaning
emerges gradually and the meaning kind
of depends on your perspective and the
intentional stance also depends on your
perspective so different agents could
look at different phenomena going on in
their physical environment and they
could describe different meaning in
their generative models so we seem to
have this kind of weird two-tier system
where no longer Nicaragua even saying
that the boundaries the mark of
boundaries are fixed they are
potentially variable and then the way
that the agents construct meaning is
also Observer dependent and all of this
is kind of touching on what I was saying
before with goals which is that the
reason they emerge is because they are
unintelligible they're extremely complex
did you see what I mean so it it feels
like the reason why we need to have this
high resolution generative model is
because in principle it would be
impossible for us to explicitly program
it
so a few quick things about that I mean
I think you're you're really identifying
some of the key issues uh I would first
so with respect to ontology
I would uh you know distinguish ontology
from metaphysics
uh ontology is just talking about what
kind of things are so when we say that
the boundaries are ontological uh what
we're saying is we're trying to capture
kind of features of the map
in some sense and you know what we've
argued uh in a paper recently is that
the free energy principle is
metaphorically speaking a map of that
part of the territory that behaves like
a map
um so uh I want to contrast this with
metaphysics in the sense that like this
is all of this is a modeling approach
this is a physics uh this isn't saying
like once and for all these boundaries
are here and crystallized and uh just
you know
are are there independently of you know
the way that we are are experiencing or
sampling or interacting with the world
like that that kind of metaphysical
stuff is not what's at stake
um yeah so in in the paper you're
referring to we describe we describe
these uh the Markov blankets as
existential boundaries uh in the sense
that they're both epistemological and
ontological they're ontological in the
sense that they are definitional of what
a thing is
in this kind of physics-based approach
if you can pick out a thing as a
physical thing then it it it
ought it has to have this blanket
structure and it's it's epistemological
in the sense that it's this interface
right like the the thing itself can only
know the world and indeed we can only
know the world the the thing through
this boundary
um okay so like this isn't meant to be a
priori it's it's sort of weird it's in
some sense it's sort of like an OP
posterior it's like an empirically
driven way to carve up the world
um
on that I I think um that that answers
my question because there's always this
um confusion about whether we're talking
about the map or the territory
and just to be clear we are we are
always talking about the map when we
talk about these boundaries
yeah the free energy principle is a map
of the boundaries you can think of and a
map of what happens when things have
boundaries that and so yeah that that is
important to keep in mind like we don't
want to engage in map territory
fallacies uh the free energy principle
is a model it's a scientific model and
it's a map and it turns out that the the
canonical way of modeling systems that
are engaged in modeling so if maximum
entropy is the canonical way of modeling
physical systems in physics uh it's it's
the way of arriving at the most
parsimonious model that generates uh you
know some data set right uh well the
free energy principle is equally a
canonical way of modeling systems that
also in turn seem to be engaged in this
kind of modeling Behavior but yeah it's
it's a model it's a map uh you know this
probably is not the final word and uh
you know we're we're uncovering some you
know
mathematical structure underneath the
free energy principle and the principle
of unitarity uh and maximum caliber and
all of this stuff that we're tentatively
calling G theory for now in homage to M
Theory from String Theory uh physics uh
so yeah uh you know as most scientific
models like the progress of science uh
means that things will probably change
like again this isn't a metaphysics this
is uh just a cohesive modeling approach
that inherits from the physics of
information and self-organization
um I would quickly just point out that
um the uh these things like seem
intrinsically related to Observer
dependence because they they are in some
deep sense uh Carl's 2019 monograph a
particular uh a pre-energy principle for
a particular physics uh ends on this
idea that the free energy principle at
core is a metrological statement where
metrological means measure theoretic or
relating to measurement and it basically
says well things that exist look as if
they're constantly measuring themselves
and like keeping themselves within
certain bounds uh so this is all and you
know this is even clearer from the
quantum information theoretic
formulation where literally what we're
saying is that the free energy principle
is a theory of observerness
uh you know the the sort of the it from
bit right like the if it's thingness but
from another perspective it's
observerness which which are kind of the
same thing
I'm sure Carl could say that again more
eloquently than I
um but I at a high level that's how I
would respond to your point
yeah Carly could do that and then also
uh since you're trying to decide if
you're in an activist you know maybe um
what other questions do we need to ask
for both of us actually to decide you
know that we haven't that we haven't
covered yet
yeah because we can we can ask Maxwell
Chris to um
um so just to pick up on that last
exchange and come back to the 300
Principle as being gloriously gray
um I think I like that because you know
the the validity of that Principle as a
method so you know as a physicist you'd
read any physical as a method something
that you apply to something
um uh I think is is underwritten not
um by its explanatory scope but by its
internal consistency with other
principles that that people do apply and
Maxwell has mentioned one
um
um I think one important example of that
you know beyond the principles of um
least actional variational principles
that underwrite for you know um
say Richard feynman's work
um uh I I'm thinking of James's maximum
entropy principle so uh Maxwell alluded
to that in terms of Maximum caliber so
maximum entropy of distributions Over
States just now becomes transformed into
distributions over
um paths when you move from when you
move uh to the maximum caliber principle
so the maximum Cowper is one is just a
Max uh jamesian Max entropy principle
for a pathological formulation
um and I think that's important to
realize the free energy principle just
is that it is just a constrained maximum
principle of Maximum entry principle and
you may ask where did the constraints
from come from that's just the geometry
model it's just in the description of
the characteristic states of pullback
attractor that constitutes the goals
we're just talking about so
um you know if you remember free energy
is just the expected energy the
constraint part plus the entropy
um and therefore
um when you're now drilling down on the
constraint part where where does that
come from it's just a description of the
pullback attractor of the characteristic
states of the system that you're trying
to uh trying to understand so I don't
really look at the three energy
Principle as something terribly new it's
been implicit there all the time it's
just people using slightly different
words for different concepts so I think
that's a kind of why I'm saying this but
it seemed important to say
um and that's what were you just talking
about because there was a link in terms
of uh were you maybe leading into the
metrological aspects the
self-measurement
I thought that was really important yes
that's right so just looking backwards
um you know what is the The Sibling of
the uh or or
um
The Sibling of the free energy principle
um of um in the past Century in the past
say a few decades I think that would be
the maximum principled constraint
maximum energy principle looking
forwards what would be the bed fellows
of the free entry principle and I think
I think that the that metrological or
relational
um thing is vitally important I and you
know I I love the work of
um
um color of Ellie and and his work with
you know
Quantum uh relational approaches to
Quantum Mechanics which is all about
relationships and of course how do you
how do you
um quantify a relationship well it's
just in terms of the interaction the
coupling which is going to be a sparse
coupling it is just a measurement it is
just an observation so inference
measurement synchronization sparse
coupling they're all the same thing and
I so I I think that what will hopefully
happen is that somebody will write down
a math possibly Dalton will write down
um a calculus that says all of these
things are just the same way of looking
at it oh and I read yesterday uh because
I had to because I was reviewing this
paper for said these about unticked
structural realism ontic structural
realism and it seems to me that that is
basically philosophers having discovered
the same
um underlying fabric the the reality is
in the measurement but it's a the
measurement of how we relate to each
other via that measurement of of of each
other or things measuring other things
purely in terms of of their
relationships so I I think that that you
know there there is a lot of if you like
um work to be done from the point of
view of fear free energy principle
theorists
in consolidating the links to what has
gone in terms of things like maximum
entry principle and what is to come in
terms of say Quantum Loop gravity or
Chris Fields um Quantum information
theoretic treatment of
um holographic screens in the Markov
blanket yeah
um at each point the fep will become
grayer because it will be less easy to
discriminate it from everything else
that stood the test of time
uh Chris do you have any comments on
that
you want to meet Chris sorry uh so yeah
I think I'll leave it there it's a bit
too deep into the philosophy for me and
we've got two experts here so I'll I'll
pass
wonderful and um to my point earlier I
mean we won't go into it now but um one
of I guess my perspective is it all
seems like epistemology to me rather
than on ontology and maybe we can um
debate that a little bit more a bit
later on but
um as our uploads are all quite slow and
I want to check that we secure this
beautiful interview I'm going to cut it
off at this point but gentlemen it's
been an absolute honor thank you so much
for coming on MLS today means so much to
me
genuinely always a pleasure gentlemen
this is uh always great fun
beautiful beautiful
yeah I always enjoy